all righty let's do this thing
it's been an emotional journey for the
actors of the kissing booth franchise
both on screen and off we've had
laughter tears a whole lot of kissing
and to top it all off some beautiful and
memorable lines
one actors first and final lines were
always done as voiceovers which major
character wound up getting together with
the first person they spoke with in the
franchise that's my best friend lee
all this happened
just because of
well
you know
it feels appropriate that our journey
begins and ends with joey king narrating
though we don't see her during either of
these her presence is very strong while
the first line is obviously about her
bff lee her final phrase is somewhat
inadvertently about him as well the
kissing booth did of course lead to her
great love with noah but it all started
between her and lee hey hey hey rule
number nine young lady
oh come on for king doing the movies was
really special especially getting to
play such a strong and cool character
since her real-life relationship with
lordy didn't work out either there was
definitely a lot of learning and growth
for both king and her character wait you
seen my athletic cup
i'll see you later okay see you okay
elorni's experience with the kissing
booth was life-changing after all he did
find love and experience a tough breakup
at the same time as noah his cheeky
opening line is the perfect intro for
his character we immediately can see
just how chill and fun a relationship he
has with his brother and elle the
character's final farewell to elle at
the same place their love story really
began is a pretty bittersweet moment we
have no doubt that the actors had all
kinds of feelings about it too
lee geronimo
oh no
[Music]
maybe going and getting some churros
okay lee starts and finishes with these
great comedic lines a pretty appropriate
choice for the always goofy and loyal
best friendly we loved getting to see
his opening line from the first movie
make another appearance in the final
film as well
while the churro line is funny it's a
pretty perfect depiction of what a great
friend he is to l keeping her best
interests at heart and making room so
she and noah could have some time
together
joel courtney is a romantic just like
his character and he felt pretty great
about the fact that lee ends up engaged
to the love of his life with his best
friends still by his side
i guess i'm next
yeah we're thinking like late may
megan's journey appropriately begins and
ends with lee it's pretty incredible
that we got to see her start her story
with him and by the final line we get
confirmation of their future together
doing the kissing booth films caused a
major shift in young's career and the
fact that she got to play a character
she loved so much was really just the
cherry on top
i take it you're the one from the
intercom
well
goodbye elle evans marco's first and
final words are with l and it feels like
the end of the marco chapter in elle's
story a pretty great one for sure we get
the fun and sassy intro then ultimately
the understanding caring great guy he is
perez was really happy with where marco
ended up since his hope for the
character was just that he lived without
regrets which definitely seems to be the
case when we last see him relax tiny
flynn this is our next door neighbor
ashton tuppin never fails to make his
presence and vibe known there's no doubt
he's a popular kid in school it is
pretty great to get to know him
throughout the movies and see him really
become a friend to the group who knew at
the beginning that elle would actually
end up missing tuppin once they all
graduated next proposal is from the
dance club
ella evans and leigh flynn best of luck
vivian definitely made a strong
impression as a leader in her class
she keeps her cool and calm demeanor
throughout even when saying farewell to
a high school pal
elle wouldn't let her go without that
hug though
good morning
hell
we all make mistakes
that's what you do after
that shows who you are elle's dad has
been there for his kids through the good
and the bad raising two children on his
own can't have been easy his first line
on screen says loads with just two words
jennings sets up their typical morning
and family dynamic he brings the perfect
bit of dad wisdom in the end and it
seems like l knows just how lucky she is
to have such an incredible father good
morning and i call the race car his
introduction in the family home as part
of the morning routine connects to his
last words when he's again hanging with
the family though this time a bit
extended the monopoly scene is a sweet
reminder of the family dynamic even if
it doesn't turn out to be the best night
in the end
hey guys
just not this one mrs flynn is a major
character in elle's story after all she
is essentially a surrogate mom for her
the ease mrs flynn has with the family
is obvious from the moment we see her we
get to see two really important parts of
her character with her first and last
lines
while we mostly think of her as a mother
we get to see what a boss businesswoman
she is as well
definitely an amazing role model for
elle
cameron aka yearbook guy he's of course
eager and ready to whip out his camera
in a flash early on in the trilogy and
by the end he's grown up and believes in
himself more as an artist
even if he isn't quite ready to see just
how skilled he is cameron's friends
won't fail to remind him
[Applause]
for whatever it's worth
i want you to know
that i think you are
an absolutely brilliant woman
meeting chloe we don't quite know how to
feel about her at first all we know is
that she's gorgeous and a new pal of
noah's it's hard not to love her by the
end with the generous and kind words she
shares with elle she definitely turned
out to be a pretty brilliant person
herself
oh so sorry
literally crashing into l when they
first meet makes a lot of sense since
linda came into l's life so unexpectedly
the two definitely have their issues but
luckily linda and elle end up finding
some common ground
rock it off
hello miss evans principal mark was
somehow always catching students in
their worst moments and of course he was
always ready his final line in the
series isn't the last time we see him
but he definitely nailed the delivery we
know he means business with al
how crazy was that fight um flynn was so
savage
have you made out with him yet
[Music]
and then there were the omg girls olivia
the o brought loads of energy off the
top playing the popular girl perfectly
the m aka mia brings total queen b
energy from the moment we see her
through to the very end
they wouldn't be omg without the g
though gwyneth rounding out the group
and unafraid to dive right in with those
personal questions by the end of the
journey it's nice to see that the
popular crew aren't actually that bad
after all
they do still call l by the wrong name
but in this case it's the thought that
counts
it has definitely been a wild journey
for the kissing booth crew
especially those we followed since the
beginning of the story
we've had the chance to see just how
much they've grown both on screen and
behind the scenes
we also can't forget elle's fantastic
final line
a perfect ending to such a special story